christopher hitchens a devout atheist if
i could say so oh yeah was a friend of
yours and referred to you as quote one
of the greatest living americans and
stated that you were one of the most
devout believers he has ever met
he further stated that you were
sequencing the genome of the cancer that
would ultimately claim his life and that
your friendship despite their differing
opinions on religion was an example of
the greatest
armed truth in modern times
what did you learn from christopher
hitchens about life or perhaps what is
the fond memory you have of this man
with whom you've disagreed but who is
also your friend
yeah i loved hitch i'm sorry he's gone
iron sharpens iron
there's nothing better uh for trying to
figure out where you are with your own
situation and your own opinions your own
world views
than encountering somebody who's
completely in another space
and who's got the gift as hitch did of
challenging everything
and uh doing so over a glass of scotch
or two or three
uh
yeah we got off to a rough start uh
where in a interaction we had at a
rather uh highbrow dinner
uh he was
really deeply insulting of a question i
was asking
but you know i was like okay
that's fine let's let's figure out how
we could have a more civil conversation
and then i really learned to greatly
admire his intellect and to find the
jousting with him
and it wasn't all about faith although
it often was
was really
inspiring and innovating energizing
and then when he got cancer i became
sort of his ally trying to help him find
pathways through
the various options and maybe helped him
to stay around on this planet for an
extra six months or so
and i have the warmest feelings of being
in his apartment uh downtown
um
over a glass of wine
talking about whatever uh sometimes it
was science he was fascinated by science
sometimes it was
thomas jefferson uh sometimes it was
faith
and i knew it would always be really
interesting
so he's now gone yeah
do you think about your own mortality
are you afraid of death
i'm not afraid i'm not looking forward
to it i don't want to rush it because i
feel like i got some things i can still
do here
but as a person of faith
i don't think i'm afraid i'm 71. i know
i don't have an infinite amount of time
left
and i want to use the time i've got in
some sort of way that matters
i'm not ready to become a full-time
golfer
[Laughter]
but i don't quite know what that is
i do feel
that i've had a chance to do amazingly
powerful things as far as experiences
and maybe god has something else in mind
i wrote this book 16 years ago
the language of god
about science and faith trying to
explain how from my perspective these
are compatible these are in harmony
they're complementary if you are careful
about which kind of question you're
asking
and to my surprise a lot of people seem
to be interested in that they were tired
of hearing the extreme voices like
dawkins at one end
and
people like ken ham and answers in
genesis on the other end saying if you
trust science you're going to hell
and they
thought there must be a way that these
things could get along and that's what i
tried to put forward and then i started
a foundation biologos which then i had
to step away from
to become nih director which has just
flourished maybe because i stepped away
i don't know
but
it now has millions of people who come
to that website and they run amazing
meetings and i think a lot of people
have really come to a sense that this is
okay i can love science and i can love
god and that's not a bad thing
so maybe there's something more i can do
in that space
maybe that book is ready for a second
edition
i think so
but when you look back
life is finite
what do you hope your legacy is
hmm
i don't know this whole legacy thing so
it's a little bit hard to
embrace it feels a little self-promoting
doesn't it i sort of feel like in many
ways i went to my own funeral
on october 5th
when i announced that i was stepping
down and i got the most amazing
responses
from people some of whom i knew really
well some of whom i didn't know at all
who were just telling me stories
about something that i had contributed
to
that made a difference to them and that
was incredibly heartwarming and that's
enough you know
i don't want to build an edifice i don't
have a plan for a monument or a statue
god help us
i do feel like i've been incredibly
fortunate i've had the chance to play a
role in things that were pretty profound
from the genome project to nih to covet
vaccines
and i had to be plenty satisfied that
i've had enough
experiences here to feel pretty good
about the way in which
my life panned out
you